in your book you have uh
you have a good light bulb joke uh how
many psychiatrists does it take to
change a light bulb
only one but the light bulb has to want
to change
i'm sorry i'm a sucker for a good light
bulb
okay so given uh you know i've been
interested in psychiatry
uh my whole life just maybe tangentially
i've kind of
early on dream to be a psychiatrist
until i understood what it entails
uh but you know what um
you know is there hope for psychiatry uh
for somebody else to help
this live wired brain to adjust
oh yeah i mean in the sense that and
this has to do with this issue about us
being trapped on our own planet
forget psychiatrists just think of like
when you're talking with a friend and
you say oh i'm so upset about this
and your friend says hey just look at it
this way
you know all we have access to under
normal circumstances is just the way
we're seeing something and so
it's super helpful to have friends and
communities and psychiatrists and so on
to
help things change that way so that
sounds like interesting help to us but
but more importantly the role that
psychiatrists have played is that
there's this sort of naive assumption
that we all come to the table with which
is that everyone is fundamentally just
like us and when you're a kid you you
believe this entirely but as you get
older and you start realizing okay
there's something called schizophrenia
and that's a real thing and to be inside
that person's head is totally different
than what it is to be inside my head
or their psychopathy and and to be
inside this psychopath's head
he doesn't care about other people he
doesn't care about hurting other people
he's just doing what he needs to do to
get what he needs
um that's a different head there's a
million different things going on
and it is different to be inside those
heads
that this is where the field of
psychiatry comes in now
i think it's an interesting question
about the degree to which neuroscience
is
leaking into and taking over psychiatry
and what the landscape will look like 50
years from now it may be that
psychiatry as a profession
you know changes a lot or maybe goes
away entirely and neuroscience will
essentially be able to take over some of
these functions but
it has been extremely useful to
understand
the differences between how people
behave and why and what you can tell
about what's going on inside their brain
just based on observation of their
behavior
you uh this this might be years ago
but i'm not sure there's an atlantic
article you've written
about moving away from a distinction
between neurological disorders
quote-unquote brain problems and
psychiatric disorders
or quote-unquote mind problems so
so on that topic how do you think about
this gray area yeah this is exactly this
is exactly the evolution that things are
going is you know there was psychiatry
and then there were guys
and gals in labs poking cells and so on
those are the neurosciences
but yeah i think these are are moving
together for exactly the reason you
decided
and where this matters a lot the
atlantic article
uh that i wrote was called the brain on
trial
where this matters a lot is it's the
legal system because
the way we run our legal system now and
this is true everywhere in the world is
you know someone shows up in front of
the judge's bench or let's say there's
five people in front of the judge's
bench and they've all committed the same
crime what we do
because we feel like hey this is fair
you're going to get the same sentence
you'll all get three years in prison or
whatever it is
but in fact brains can be so different
this guy's got schizophrenia this guy's
psychopath this guy's tweaked down on
drugs and so on so
that um it actually doesn't make sense
to keep doing that and what we what we
do in this country more than anywhere in
the world
is we imagine that incarceration is a
one-size-fits-all solution and you may
know we have the
america has the highest incarceration
rate in the whole world in terms of the
percentage of our population we put
behind bars
so um there's a much more refined thing
we can do
as neuroscience comes in and changes and
has the opportunity to change the legal
system
which is to say this doesn't let anybody
off the hook it doesn't say oh it's not
your fault and so on
but what it does is it changes the
equation so it's not about
hey how blameworthy are you but instead
is about
hey what do we do from here what's the
best thing to do from here so if you
take somebody with schizophrenia and you
have them
break rocks in the hot summer sun in a
chain gang all
yeah that that doesn't help the
schizophrenia that doesn't fix the
problem
um if you take somebody with a drug
addiction who's in jail for you know
being caught two ounces of some illegal
substance
and you put him in prison it doesn't
actually fix the addiction it doesn't
help anything
um happily what neuroscience and
psychiatry bring to the table
is lots of really useful things you can
do with schizophrenia with drug
addiction things like this
and that's why so i i don't know if you
know but i run a national non-profit
called the center for science and law
and it's all about this intersection of
neuroscience and legal system
and we're trying to implement changes in
every county and every state
um i'll just without going down that
rabbit hole i'll just say one of the
very simplest things to do is to set up
specialized court systems where you have
a
mental health court that has judges and
juries with
expertise in mental illness because if
you go by the way to a regular court and
the person says
um or the defense lawyer says this
person has schizophrenia
most of the jury will say man i call
[ __ ] on that why because they
don't know about because they don't they
don't know what it's about
and it turns out people who who know
about schizophrenia
feel very differently as a juror than
someone who happens not to know anybody
schizophrenia they think it's an excuse
so you have judge insurance with
expertise in mental illness and they
know the rehabilitative strategies that
are available
that's one thing having a drug court
where you have judges injuries with
expertise and rehabilitative strategies
and what can be done and so on
a specialized prostitution court and so
on all these different
uh things by the way this is very easy
for counties to implement this sort of
thing
and this is this is i think where this
matters to get
neuroscience into public policy what's
the process of
injecting expertise into this so yeah
i'll tell you exactly what it is
a county needs to run out of money first
i've seen this happen over and over
so what happens is a county has a
completely full jail and they say you
know what
we need to build another jail and then
they realize god we don't have any money
we can't afford this we've got too many
people in jail
and that's when they turn to god we need
something smarter and that's when they
set up specialized court systems
oh we all function best when when our
back is against the wall
and that's what kovitt is good for yeah
it's because we we've all had our
routines and we are
optimized for the things we do and
suddenly our backs are against the wall
all of us
yeah it's really i mean one of the
exciting things about
uh kovitt i mean i'm a big believer in
the the possibility of what government
can do for the people and uh
when it becomes too big of a bureaucracy
it starts functioning poorly
starts wasting money it's nice to uh
i mean kobe isn't reveals that nicely
and
lessons to be learned about who gets
elected
and who goes into government hopefully
this
hopefully this inspires talented
and young people to go into government
to revolutionize different aspects of it
yeah so it's uh this that's the positive
silver lining of covid
you